[Gelächter]
[Musik]
viele leute meint er ist auch werden und
dass sie sich schon
[Musik]
das ist ein bisschen üben was müssen wir
bilden kampfschwimmer und pionier
taucher aus die aufgabe der prämiert
auch es unter wasser zu arbeiten wir
können mit dem hämmern steine bearbeiten
wir können mit motor sieben holz
bearbeiten was ich mal als geraden einem
hocker der vorbereitet wird für einen
tauchgang bis 40 meter klasse
[Musik]
was muss ich dann über den abstiegskampf
immer sind die amtlichen kräfte bisher
kommandos sie führen unter wasser
angriffe mit niemand durchgreifen
objekte im land mehr an und führen
aufklärungs aufgaben durch und das ganze
vollkommen unbemerkt wir haben auch
geräte die mit sauerstoff betrieben
werden und die keine blasen erzeugen man
sieht uns nicht kommen neptuns dunkle
schöner hier auch gerne nennt dunkler
sohn lebt uns geschaffen dass das kannst
du mit uns machen jetzt jetzt
bevor du ins freiwasser und eine übung
mit uns machst musst du noch ins heim
bad hall war das gut
die jungen sind schon vorbereitet
dann legen wir los ab
die zeit läuft 32
[Musik]
unter wasser heraus viele wie zu
verteidigen
[Musik]
das ist das spezialgerät gekämpft da
kommt verrückter ausgewandert hoben geld
und die zeit alle robert hainbad phase
erledigt mit beginnen mit einem
arbeitstag können wir uns im dorf gerät
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe meinen pionier der
schnupperkurs einmal fürs erste erledigt
jetzt schauen wir uns an was die
menschen machen deren profession das ist
[Musik]
was für ein helikopter ins wasser unter
wasser zu lande zone landet so eine
sicherheits dank der kollegen sie an den
pionieren signalisieren dass sowie
[Musik]
landes ohne ist aufgeklärt und gesichert
ihr könnt's nachrücken zeichen wird
gesetzt
[Musik]
viele wenn sie gedacht haben wie was das
bundesheer hat auch und was für welche
ich habe hier ein einblick gewonnen in
eine unglaubliche gruppe auf der einen
seite bieten ihre die arbeit die schon
an land schwer sie unter wasser extrem
genial erledigung auf der einen seite
krank schwimmer pi nicht nur bares nord
rabl sich und erklären können und in
jeden noch so schwierigen einsatzgebiet
zu hause und da noch die beiden verbände
gemeinsam auf einsicht passiert ihre
aufgaben erfüllen
das war ist nicht tolle erfahrung aber
achtung ihr habt ja glaubt dieser job
wäre jedenfalls vollkommen recht
okay war passiert
wissen sie ich super gemacht gratulierte
ebenfalls aufgeführten oder das wasser
verbracht wir brauchen dich zum heer ist
auch von der stadt
über eine freundin
[Musik]